darkest dungeon it turned a bunch of
money four times its Kickstarter goal
feels like years ago at this stage came
ours already accessed last year I
remember yourself and Alexa to the video
stream of it was about one year ago yeah
so now it's like officially yes and Mike
you haven't reviewed it for GameSpot we
have one of our freelancers yeah Daniel
Starck okay cool it's up today it's all
for this morning
oh really yeah awesome yeah but you've
been playing it as well recently I have
yeah first of all your thoughts how does
it play did you play at all during its
already access release very like only a
little bit probably like a few hours at
most
I know Maryanne Alexa like we just
mentioned played more than I did so I
was curious I kept asking them about it
because I wanted to play it but yeah we
had the review went up it was 9 out of
10 like the problems Daniel had were
they're very much in line with mine it's
very good all around except you know
like it can be overwhelming as far as
the menus go and it's kind of like
obtuse in that sense but yeah the game
is great it's really good for folks you
don't know much about this game and Mary
I'm not sure if you played recently
again yeah the affliction system you
talk a little bit about that that's the
whole thing where people basically in
this game kind of are constantly on the
edge you going crazy right that's right
it's kind of an additional gambling
system of death where you you know it's
a turn-based RPG you're just kind of
dungeon crawling you could consider it a
roguelike in the sense that everything
is generated and it's perma death and
you know random things can happen but
the affliction system is this additional
element it kind of gives it a bit more
unique sense that you every character
that's in these dungeons can have
afflictions happen to them whether that
be fear or the opposite maybe they
become really rabid or cold and they
just think they're the best and they're
just like really into themselves and all
of a sudden they will do things without
you telling them to do that right they
will they will switch what whether their
first or last in turn they will refuse
to do what you tell them they'll attack
randomly without without you doing
anything I saw one where there was
somebody who was so close to death that
she just refused to take medical
assistance
I'm dead going to die anyway like
hopeless or masochistic is another
characteristic though just they'll like
get in front of other people who are
getting a pact because they just really
need punishment yeah for like one reason
other a lot of them are they
characterized a lot of them some there's
actually a few that are like anti beast
so if you have saw a werewolf in your
party rapes yes someone someone who like
I forget that like like like can't throw
fob or something I don't know they hate
werewolf so like in yeah you try to
bring them in the same party they'll be
like I'm not going near that foul
creature yeah yeah and then the let's
say that because they get this
affliction and they I don't know they
act out of turn and then they actually
die from it yeah the wolf will feel bad
really
okay because he because of who he is
he's causing people in his party to die
and to feel guilty about it and he'll
feel like [ __ ] and he won't want to go
out so you after these really aggressive
and they're all terrible nothing good
happens in this game you guys know like
the very first thing that happens to
Neelix is we read a book and it was a it
was a bad book and it scares the [ __ ]
out of our person yeah made him scared
for the whole turn so they come back and
they are miserable or they feel terrible
and it's your job to treat them to the
best of your ability whether that be
take them to a brothel or you know to a
bar oh yeah let them relax it's a huge
and there's a lot of realistic elements
to this game that after you've gone
through some [ __ ] you got to figure out
what's the best way to let them cope
whether that be through religion or
booze or yeah some of them will be like
atheist so you can't have them pray okay
because that's not gonna do anything to
them and then some are like alcoholics
so you shouldn't put them in the bar
right and yeah so that's there's nothing
at no point during the like dozen or so
hours I played this game that I feel in
control until later until later you
start to have like level 8 and higher
heroes because they think a while to
rank up you know either
it's pretty persistent but later on you
actually start to have these good
characters but you still
kind of accept that like bad shits gonna
happen think it's meant to be a hard
game yeah yeah this is a game that's
like this it's not it's like Dark Souls
it's not just like unfair I
intentionally meant to be difficult yeah
no I would like darks right right no no
no right I would it's very much I don't
like a lot of it is not your kind of
just okay that's unfair but that's what
I got into yeah yeah so it's turkey says
it in his review really well which is
that it's almost become cliche to say
that it's Dark Souls s so many people
freaking say that when it comes to a
game being difficult but this game truly
deserves the nod because it's difficult
in the sense that although it is going
to throw a lot at you you have
everything at in your ability to help
prevent these measures think of it like
and start you said this is well really
well like a like a poker you don't know
what card is gonna be dealt but if
you're a good player you're eventually
going to win so this game is teaching
you to become a good player you're going
to lose again and again and again and
it's gonna consistently you know
sometimes you're gonna have a bad roll
of the dice and you're gonna read a bad
book yeah but if you're good you should
have a plan ready for when that happened
yeah that's a really fair point it is
like crazy how like I even said it
myself I said it's like a Dark Souls
game was like difficult yeah but you
were saying before that there's like
there is this sort of weird little
Renaissance of difficult difficult games
I guess is the way to say it was a Jake
Solomon you were talking to him yeah I
was talking to Jake Solomon like lead
designer creative director over at for
access on XCOM and Garth DeAngelis the
producer and we were talking about how
just this year with between Tharsis the
witness I just can't see the darkest
dungeon and the Dark Souls 3 is coming
out soon but this is like the biggest
clump of really difficult games we've
had and I think we all have recognized
because a lot of people around the
office have been saying like I don't
remember the last time I played a game
where I like felt comfortable
well that here's like the mass Marcus
success of games like Call of Duty like
games that you know aren't they're
challenging that it's like an easy ramp
for you like games like not to
constantly going on to my first person
games well the games like this and the
games I want you to play but like have
that like difficulty ramp that's quite
it's difficult it's forgiving yeah it's
like allowing you to like level up or
whatever like these are games that force
difficult questions on you right yeah
then you you know you
the complete opposite which you know
like this is a stigma that's been
attached to Nintendo with a lot of stuff
is that they handhold I mean right it's
not sure with everything but yeah I know
they like I had mentioned it when I was
playing the witness a lot it felt like
the first game in a while that actually
just us like respected my intelligence
not other games weren't but to such an
extent that it like it has confidence
that you can really figure out it knows
you're a smart person that kind of
rewards you for you know it rewards you
for playing and agreeing with it I guess
and like a weird sense and it's nice to
have that refreshing yeah must be
difficult to make games like that yeah
especially like looking at something
like the witness and this game who seems
to have a lot going on where you really
have to like trusts you have that you
have to get the player to trust you yeah
that the game isn't broken but it's not
like it's you it's not the game yeah and
the witness is such a good example of a
difficulty curve in a game because
although there are puzzles in there that
are insane and they will absolutely rock
you there's nothing there's no stone
left unturned that Jonathan Blow didn't
specifically intend for it to be in that
game and you'll know that moment because
when you do solve it you'll go oh I'm an
idiot it was there the whole time if I
would have looked around there are clues
everywhere and that happens in a lot of
games if you I mean give them some
credit you know a lot of this is player
you know you got to improve your own
skills to really understand when you get
that enlightenment it's such a good
feeling anyway next comes who was a lot
like down the office because there was
some folks who cuz ex-cons who's harder
next come one yeah so then you're
playing X I'm 2 and being like I'm not
so sure if this is like as finely tuned
as ex-con 1 and it is you just kinda
have to change your mentality when
you're going into it yeah I think it
shows and that the tutorial gives you
the fundamentals that people play to
enemy unknown enemy other then should
have a grasp of and I'm sure like
hardcore veterans of enemy Unknown maybe
bumped out the difficulty right away I
played a lot but I hadn't played in a
while so I played in default and after
the tutorial was immediately clear how
many layers I wasn't shown right at the
beginning and I think it shows
confidence that you know these are smart
people they can figure it out in their
own I think they're they know that this
the failure is supposed to be meaningful
and you're supposed to fail yeah and I
think that's kind of like a really cool
idea it's it's been
before but it's just like like Garth and
Jake had been saying when I was
interviewing them about ex-con - it's
kind of a lot more games or I think are
willing to do that right now they want
to give you the responsibility and with
that comes the reward you know if that's
right if it says that this shot has a
95% chance to hit and it doesn't do you
blame the game and say well my stupid
shooter got that 5% or do you
acknowledge that you should be prepared
for the chance that it might not hit
it's giving you that power and that
responsibility and that's a great thing
so final thoughts on darkest dungeon and
then I kind of swiveled you guys away
from that for a little bit mine at a
time it's $24.99 on Steam people haven't
played it recommend they pick it up
definitely yeah
if you're in the mood for a difficult
game but like we were just saying one
that kind of has confidence you're gonna
figure it out go for it it's it's really
good 9 out of 10 definitely very
deserving more based off me absolutely I
couldn't recommend it enough it is
gut-wrenching but it's it's absolutely a
well-deserved score it's a good game and
you should pick it up and you feel like
you know what else it is to kickstart a
game that [ __ ] came out and was good
for them was a second one over
you